et le grand jeu hier était dans la
région paca où c'est finalement le
président sortant les républicains qui
est réélu 57,3 % des voix vous loyer
pour renaud muselier 42 7% pour thierry
mariani du rassemblement national
on va faire le point tout de suite à
marseille avec notre reporter sur place
david khalifa
[Musique]
bonjour david vous avez suivi hier
évidemment ces résultats avec la défaite
de thierry mariani face à renaud
muselier quelle est l'ambiance quel est
l'état d'esprit ce matin à marseille a
bien écouté c'est une énorme déception
pour retirer
mariani encore un raté voilà comment on
peut définir en deux mots cette soirée
électorale pour le rassemblement
national et le candidat thierry mariani
les résultats ont à nouveau trahi les
promesses de sondage et le rassemblement
national se retrouve toujours sans
région pourtant
souvenez-vous à l'issue à dieu un
premier tour thierry mariani constituer
la meilleure chance de victoire pour la
formation de marine le pen mais elle son
score décevant à plus de dix points de
son adversaire nos muselier constitue
une sorte de claque on peut le dire pour
le rassemblement national est ce qui
devait être une fête pour les militants
du candidat s'est transformé en une
véritable soupe à la grimace
et c'est dans le 10e arrondissement de
marseille que thierry mariani avait elle
choisi l endroit pour célébrer une
victoire qui n'a pas eu lieu finalement
environ 600 militants étaient attendus
n'étaient qu'une poignée
hier soir est thierry mariani a quand
même assumer cette défaite avec beaucoup
d'amertume
elle vous l'imaginez l'eurodéputée
dénonce une bataille inégale après les
appels à lui faire barrage et le retrait
de la liste de gauche écoutez c'est avec
une grande tristesse que je dois
constater ce soir notre défaite
le changement que tant attendu n'aura
pas lieu
le système coalisés l'emporter au terme
d'une campagne qui n'honore pas nos
adversaires
je veux d'abord avoir une pensée pour
tous nos électeurs
tous ceux qui ont permis qu'un espoir se
lève en provence alpes côte d'azur
c'est avant tout pour eux pour notre
région et pour son avenir que je suis
triste une énorme déception vous venez
de l'entendre principal responsable
également le taux de participation a de
son côté le candidat républicain renaud
muselier s'est félicité d'avoir gagné
face aux périls à de l'extrême droite la
logique d'unité elle sort vainqueur et a
démenti tous les pronostics selon ses
mots écoutez depuis le premier jour
c'est la logique du rassemblement qui a
animé notre bilan notre équipe notre
méthode est notre projet depuis le
premier jour nous appuyons sur une
majorité sortante qui a démontré sa
force pendant la crise sans jamais
laisser personne sur le bord du chemin
ce soir cette logique d'unité et
d'efficacité l'a emporté ce soir c'est
notre région qui a gagné vous les
conventions les haltères et les azuréens
vous avez fait un choix fondateurs et
décisif vous avez été scrutés décortiqué
analysé depuis plusieurs mois comme le
futur laboratoire du front national on
nous promettait un destin de cobaye nous
avons opté pour un destin de région
libre nous avons refusé la fatalité
d'une région gouvernée par l'extrême
droite
cette décision nous l'avons prise en
conscience au delà des clivages
politiques
nous avons pris notre destin en main
nous avons pris notre destin en mains en
dehors des appareils politiques
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que cette
soirée électorale à marque la fin d'une
campagne éprouvante pour thierry mariani
et la fin d'un duel extrêmement tendues
entre les deux hommes comment analyser
finalement cette victoire les
républicains et en région paca david
le sec la région paca a une relation
particulière avec le rassemblement
national souvenez vous en 2015 marion
maréchal-le pen avait enregistré des
scores records lors du premier tour avec
45 55 % des suffrages au premier tour
mais la figure montante du parti n'avait
pas réussi à réitérer l'exploit au
second tour et six ans plus tard
finalement thierry mariani reproduit
exactement le même scénario
la pièce maîtresse est de marine le pen
la victoire de l'ancien maire de valréas
dans cette région ont résonné comme un
exploit pour le parti qui n'a jamais de
remporter deux régions dans son histoire
à l'enjeu reste tout de même crucial
pour marine le pen en vue de 2022
mais avec cette victoire républicaine eh
bien on a l'impression que le
rassemblement national touche encore son
plafond de verre c'est comme ça qu'on
peut le dire
et puis est-ce qu'il faut prendre avec
un certain recul
évidemment c'est le taux d'abstention
une nouvelle fois élevé dans la région
paca estimé à plus de 62% marine le pen
a d'ailleurs eu la défaite amère elle
condamne une organisation de scrutin à
désastreuse
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
mettre toute mon énergie et ma volonté à
réhabiliter la politique à le rendre son
utilité la présidentielle apparaît plus
que jamais comme l'élection qui permet
de changer à la politique
fin de citation vous l'aurez compris
malgré cette défaite est bien la
présidente du rassemblement national
anticipe en vue des élections
présidentielles merci beaucoup pour tout
ses explications ce matin en direct de
marseille david khalifa merci